thank you thank you for the introduction
my name is Emily Gorski
full-stack with data science full-stack
is not a phrase that we hear very often
in regards to data science and i confess
that i kind of put it in the title as a
little bit of a hook to get you in
interested in the topic but let's I want
to kind of set an intention for what
this talk is my goal here is to talk
about data science as an integral
component of a team in an organization
that is inseparable from all of the
other components of your organization
your engineering teams your design teams
your QA teams and your customer
relations legal compliance all of those
things that we have heard about and
talked about throughout this conference
and how to integrate data science with
that very effectively this talk comes
from a place of having many many
discussions with data scientists in
organizations of all shapes and sizes
and hearing many of the same problems
over and over and over some of them
dealing with the difficulty of
production izing our work some of them
dealing with the difficulty of
convincing our stakeholders of the value
of what we do so if you're looking for
like some really great technical you
know marvel I don't have that here what
I'm hoping that you take away from this
talk is a way to structure your work as
a data scientist and to really advocate
for yourself and your for your teammates
let me there we go now it's working I'm
so a little bit about myself I am a
mathematician by degree and an
aeronautical engineer by training I've
been working in data science for the
last couple of years and I'm also a
political activist by necessity
all three of those things are important
all three of those things have informed
this talk and by way of a small plug
I've co-authored a chapter recently for
the book that's coming out by David
Blanc Edelman the book is called seeking
sree sree stands for site reliability
engineering it's a different topic than
most data scientists are
involved in but hopefully you'll see the
parallels in this talk with some of the
techniques and practices that site
reliability engineers have developed
over the course of their profession
and I wrote this chapter with my very
good friend Liz Fong Jones about
organizing in the workplace and
understanding how the work that we do
intersects with society at large so
there's my little plug for you so let's
start with an example suppose that you
work for a social media site and your
CTO calls you into a meeting and says
hey you're the data scientist we've got
this problem there's a lot of hate
speech on our platform and I need you to
fix it what do you do anybody shout out
an answer I'm an anarchist so whoever
shouts first and loudest is is the
winner
machine learning okay so we're going to
machine learn hate speech out of our
platform any specific ideas any any
techniques that we've learned about this
weekend sentiment analysis there we go
okay so you come your CTO says we need
to identify hate speech on our platform
and and prevent it and you say okay
that's great I've got this algorithm
with sentiment analysis the problem is
that's not the solution that the CTA is
asking for that's how to identify hate
speech in your data what the CTO is
asking for is how do you identify hate
speech on your platform and those are
two very different problems because it's
one thing to work in data it's another
thing to be able to take your data and
build it into a comprehensive effective
tool product or feature with your
platform service or organization so
let's talk about what full stack means
and in order to do this we're going to
try time travel a little bit back to
1998 and I pick 1998 because there's a
joke that says that full stack is
wherever the top of the stack is when
you started your career to wherever the
top of the stack is now and I started my
career sort of in 1998 and you maybe you
don't believe that I'm old enough to do
that and I actually have found a
fountain of youth
and I will confess that it is a bit of a
commitment so I don't recommend it
unless you need to
but 1998 the what was the web looking
like the web was mostly static content
we had some dynamic tools there was some
dynamic development going on in the web
and it was things like CGI we had like
early PHP like PHP 1 & 2 ASP before
dotnet existed there was a sp1 and
version 1 and 2 existed before dotnet
was even in its beta s HTML ColdFusion
all sorts of all these technologies and
clouds like that concept was a weather
that was like a meteorological term
which may seem strange nowadays um but
because of these technologies because
this was something that was really
evolving rapidly there were a lot of
really bad practices and so I dug up
some 20 year old code and this is a game
called point out the codes him so this
is code that I actually wrote for this
gaming site that I made when I was 20
years ago old and this is like these are
practices that they advocated for in
books like table based layouts absolute
positioning this is like I guess CSS did
exist but we weren't using it
that's a database query in a view
component with I think that's a password
in the source code and then there's like
a sequel injection vulnerability sitting
right there so like this is this was
common stuff and what happened was
people wrote a lot of this code and it
was terrible and as the internet grew in
users grew exponentially it didn't scale
and so we came up with this idea of
separating concerns into a stack so that
you have your back-end development your
front-end development and this is sort
of the paradigm that has carried forward
and still exists today
and in the late 90s early 2000s there
are a couple things happening in the
technology industry one of them being
that Java was kind of the dominant
language within the software engineering
enterprise space you also had like a lot
of people making a lot of money in COBOL
because of y2k but if you weren't doing
y2k remediation you were probably
writing Java if you are in a software
engineering field if you wanted to be
like the cool hip person like Java
develop Java EE back then was like I
don't know if you're like a reactive L
up or now so we kind of separated these
components and one of the paradigms that
came out of this was
model-view-controller
there's also a model view viewmodel
which is a terrible phrase there's
database layers and then they were
middleware and there was all sorts of
stuff and so we've over the course of
several years developed this idea of
separating concerns and removing your
view components your front-end
components from your database from your
all your architectural code and so we
get came up with this vague split
between back-end and front-end web
engineering but if you look at a typical
tech company now there's so much more
than just back in in front-end and we
don't typically include this in our
definitions of full stack like if
somebody says oh I'm a full stack
engineer like you should start quizzing
them on security and infrastructure and
DevOps and design and compliance because
all of those things are necessary
components to actually deploying our
tech stack the question is when we have
all of this these separations of roles
that have exploded over the past several
years where does data science fit in and
that's a question that a lot of
organizations are really struggling with
like we want to be able to make use of
our data and we want to build products
that can use data but we don't really
know where it fits into this very deep
convoluted scheme that we've made of how
to separate rolls and so like depending
on what your organization might do data
science can fit in all over the place
some organizations
it's in front-end like they do smart UX
they do tracking some data scientists or
just doing analytics you know they're
not really a data science team they're
data analytics team um some of them are
doing backend you have like a model you
write it up maybe you're doing fraud
detection or something like that and
then you write up a bunch of code and
then you deploy a micro service and then
some companies like IOT there's a lot of
this work doing streaming
transformations and building out your
infrastructure to train and deploy
models in sort of an automated
continuous delivery sense so data
science really does fit all over what we
call the tech stack so here's a question
for you raise your hand if you're a data
scientist and you have to do on-call
shifts that's one person what one and a
half people one person is kind of like
yeah okay so like most most data
scientists don't have to do on call
ships and why do I bring this up it's
because if we want to actually build a
models and have them in the critical
pathway of our systems if we really want
to make data science valuable we need to
think about putting ourselves in that
role and making data science inseparable
from the rest of our stack so it means
that there is a future where if you're
the data scientist you get called up at
four in the morning to do some emergency
calculus so typical organizations will
have it the data science doesn't work
like a stack and the ideal scenario it
works more like a cycle and depending on
your organization it could be that
you're working most of your work is an
algorithm development there's lots of
really cool talks here about computer
vision and NLP and stuff like that maybe
that's where you focus or maybe you're
doing more feature engineering and
you're you really don't need to use the
latest and greatest but you can get a
lot of value out of just some linear or
logistic regression and with your data
the problem is all of your data is kind
of a mess or maybe you're doing model
building and you your organization has
pick
a type of model and you're just working
through your data and automating
processes to deploy that technology or
maybe you're doing product felt maybe
you're doing analytics but the point is
that this is a feedback cycle so if you
want to develop a feature that makes
your product better you need to do and
to use data in some intelligent way you
need to go through this whole cycle
because you need to get that feedback
from when it's deployed how are people
using it is it actually giving us the
value that we are looking for out of the
future so what does this mean in terms
of full stack so what is our full data
stack I'm not going to read through all
this but it could contain many things
from building measurement and data
collection techniques instrumenting our
web views it could be building
experimentation like a bee testing but
better than a bee testing it could be
going through and doing machine learning
it could be building dashboards and
communicating to stakeholders lots of
things and so as a data scientist you
might have to be good at a whole host of
skills from doing computational math to
actually robust software engineering to
data base modeling or even dealing with
gdpr type stuff ethics and compliance
and business cases so a data scientist
has to have a lot of skills to give an
example this is a data science stack
that I've have some familiarity with the
number of technology components that we
had in the stack if you were to look
from the minute that we collected data
on a user to the final result of using
that data we had we started with basic
math and stats jupiter' notebooks
throwing sequel at things we had
multiple databases Postgres and
production redshift for analytics we had
Kafka doing stream processing all sorts
of stuff we had a fully Scala back-end
and then some like Python tooling on top
of that to handle our data all the way
down to actually using Salesforce and
there were even Excel spreadsheets that
we had
in the stack so this is like a massive
amount of knowledge that any one person
would have to have the good news is that
there's no such thing as a full stack
data scientist so if that's giving you
anxiety great you don't have to worry
about all of those things and there's no
such thing as a full stack engineer and
anyone that tells you that they are a
full second genera is really minimizing
the contributions of all of the people
around them that are making the
technology work but we can build full
stack teams and so that's what the last
part of this talk is about and so that
was a long-winded introduction to what I
really want to talk about which is a
model for how to build a full stack data
science team so these are the the the
Mars rovers these are three generations
of Mars rovers there's the little cute
one which was named Oh what was its name
I forget Sojourner was that Sojourner
that was Sojourner and then there is
spirit I think or one of the Spirit
Opportunity Rovers and then curiosity
and so this is a test that NASA ran
testing these Rovers in the desert I
think in Arizona in the United States
and this is interesting because in order
to validate the technology NASA had to
take these Rovers and create an
environment that was similar to Mars
except where on earth were not on Mars
so it's very difficult to to find that
environment but there's no way that they
could launch a multi-billion dollar
device to another planet without having
tried to at least validate it in a
realistic environment and so in order to
measure the development of complex
systems in the 1970s NASA developed
something called the Technol technology
readiness level scale or TRL TRL's were
nine levels of technology readiness from
one which represented basic research to
nine which represented a system being
proven in an operational environment and
these models were really useful to
target where you were in the development
process of complex systems
and these models if you have been a
government contractor in particularly in
the United States as I have been when
you do research oftentimes when you
write the grant you say okay at the end
of the at the end of this research cycle
I expect to deliver technology at a TRL
level of four or six or whatever it
might be and the purpose of this is not
to I mean it is a little bit to deal
with legal stuff and grantsmanship and
all that but it's really to be able to
have a consistent way of communicating
across teams where you are in your
development process and so we can take
this and adapt this to our industry and
this is something that we don't often do
in our agile / Kanban / scrum type of
universe but this TRL's were adapted by
many different engineering bodies over
the years and this is a European
Commission model which i think is really
useful because it Maps very well to the
technology industry and to data science
and so we start with basic principles
being observed at the bottom and as we
bubble up we start talking about
validating technology in relevant
environments and labs operational
environments all the way up to systems
being proven in the field so if we
wanted to write like look at this in a
view of how do we do this in a web
centric engineering space this is what a
typical full stack development process
looks like you kind of come up with the
need or the shortcoming you identify the
technology concept you start programming
you write your tests your test pass you
push it to development environment or
you know a dev branch hopefully the
tests past there then you have QA people
and then maybe you do a beta release -
like your employees if you if you make
your employees use your software and
then once that's passed you're ready for
staging then you ship it to prod and you
hope that everything works great and if
you look at how the team's interact you
can really start to to see that this
process involves more than just your
engineering teams
the question is where do we fit data
science in this and right now most data
science teams within orgs are really at
the early levels we're doing algorithm
development we're doing research on our
data we're maybe building some
technology and then we do some stuff and
then hopefully we get it to running in
prod and then if we're really good about
closing the loop we also do analytics on
what we're doing on whether or not
that's been effective and then we feed
that back into the next development
cycle so that we continue iterating on
our product so let's kind of go through
and talk about data science readiness in
this framework so basic principles
observed that might be like algorithm
design and then we move up to technology
concept formulated that's kind of like
exploring our data doing feature
extraction maybe doing some basic
descriptive statistics the next step
experimental proof of concept that
doesn't need any adaptation at all this
is a lot of what we do in say a Jupiter
notebook or in whatever the our version
is I don't use our technology validated
in lab well maybe we validate our
algorithms against sample data once we
have the actual code working well maybe
you know hopefully we do cross
validation or some other type of
validation when we develop our
algorithms and then we look at the
relevant environment well that's prade
data demonstrating tech in the relevant
environment well that's when we start to
integrate it with the rest of our
technology and then the last three three
levels need no change this is exactly
where we want to be they very accurately
describe in my opinion what a mature
data science product looks like and we
can kind of conceptually separate this
into discovery versus delivery the early
phases our discovery the later phases
our delivery and these are two different
skill sets that you need as a data
scientist so let's go through this
example of doing you know I hate speech
platform so maybe you have read a blog
post or listen to a conference talk and
you have this great idea for sentiment
analysis and so you're at TRL one and
then you pull some data and you open up
a jupiter notebook and you start doing
some basic stuff like are we even
collecting the data do we have messages
do we have text can we even detect hate
speech and you throw it together a
jupiter notebook and then you know maybe
your next step is we throw together a
jupiter notebook with cross-validation
and then you're ready for the next level
you're like all right i've got the
sample dataset it's working great i want
to do it against prod hopefully you have
an analytics environment but if you
don't you go to your DBA and you say i
promise if you give me permission i
won't delete anything and then if that
works then who knows there's kind of a
maybe you staple something together and
you can put it in prod but then you get
to the green money part right that's
where we all want to be the hard part is
that transition between the discovery
phase and the delivery phase and often a
lot of that difficulty is because as
data scientists other engineers don't
understand our work so we have a very
difficult time communicating with them
so we can do better than this and my
recommendation is that we set intentions
and target outcomes to use the model
that contracting uses where you say by
the end of this work iteration I'm going
to have my technology at a certain
readiness level and when you can set
that you know what resources will need
to be engaged as you move forward so to
take this example the hate-speech
example as a working model so rather
than saying okay I'm going to solve the
problem going to deploy a machine
learning algorithm and then we're going
to everything is going to be great we
have to think of it in terms of work
iterations and so the first one is can
we even solve the problem as stated like
do we even have the data and so this is
like early phase work maybe we have the
data do we know how to build the
algorithm like does it actually work on
our systems and the answer to this could
be no and then you might go back to you
CTO and say sorry we don't we need to
react cheer Accord the data we don't
have anything but suppose that we
actually do so you might engage your
data scientists and data engineers at
this point and if that passes we'll go
on to the next step what does a Minimum
Viable Product look like and this at
this point you should be engaging thing
people like your designers and your
product managers so that they can manage
the process of your work as you move
forward and you may even fail at this
because you may not come up with a good
solution of what a product
I mean Viable Product looks like and
that would tell you that like you could
do all the best machine learning in the
world but you're not going to get to a
place where it's going to work because
it doesn't fit in with the rest of your
product vision assuming you can do that
the next question is how do we build the
MVP and at this point you need to be
engaging other people you need to be
engaging your back-end team your
front-end team your infrastructure team
and figuring out how things work and
then if that works then you move on how
do we ship the MVP and you bring in even
more people and this is where you have
compliance legal QA all of that stuff
and what we're doing here is we're
engaging people early in the process so
that we don't get to the points where
we're having difficulties with like oh
we've deployed a machine learning
algorithm why is it now all of a sudden
banning all these people from our
platform that we didn't want to ban and
creating a huge public relations
nightmare for us not that I'm looking at
any social media platforms when I think
of this example and then finally how do
we improve the MVP so we've deployed
something how do we cycle back and
actually take our data take our
knowledge and then keep identifying you
know identify the weaknesses identify
what what is good at and then improve
this product and so then we bring in
even more teams we'll bring in our
customer relations team we'll bring in
our analytics team the point is that if
you want to be a full-stack data science
team if you're not working with design
if you're not working with customer
relations if you're not working with the
other parts of your organization
or your client clients organization
you're not doing full-stack data science
you're just doing algorithm development
so I kind of want to have a few minutes
left so I want to wrap up with some
takeaways that will hopefully be
something that you can bring back to
your work
for how to actually use this kind of
conceptual model to become a full-stack
data science team so the first takeaway
is that we have to think of data science
as more than just turn algorithms into
money when you start a work cycle know
where you are and know where you're
going to where you want to end and then
engage stakeholders who are needed at
your target readiness level at the
beginning of your work cycle so this is
as a really good example of this I
worked for an organization that had a
fully JVM based back-end and if we
wanted to put anything into our
production environment it needed to be
running on the JVM which is great until
we developed all this really cool Python
tools and the problem with that was well
we could stand up a flask app or we
could do you know some like use PMML or
we could actually just manually code the
stuff in Scala but nobody actually knew
how to do anything with our technology
and so we developed all of this cool
work and we spent a ton of time and
energy in it but we didn't have anyone
that could actually support that work so
if we wanted to stand up a Python micro
service that did all of this you know
cool recommendation work we actually
would have needed to hire somebody that
could maintain a Python micro service in
production and we needed to hire DevOps
people to handle the deployment or we
needed to do on-call shifts as data
scientists and we weren't paid for that
so we need to be able to engage your
stakeholders early on if we were able to
do that we probably could have done a
lot better rather than say hey we built
this model now ship it and everyone's
like well we don't know how the another
key takeaway is failure is normal we
should be failing as data
scientists very often if you're not
failing you're not innovating in a sense
most of the time we're going to look at
data and we're going to say maybe I can
get a pattern out of this maybe I can
build a model out of this and then it's
not going to work and we have to keep
iterating this is a normal research
process and so you can't just say I'm
going to start at the early level and
I'm going to develop all the way up to
the end and it's going to be great if
you're not having some stumbling then I
really question you know whether or not
what you're doing is actually effective
so failures normal and the process is
not monotonic you should often have to
reset yourself to a lower technology
readiness level as you do this work
different readiness levels also require
different skills this is a critically
important thing as we look at building
data science teams people who are good
at computational math may not be good at
visualization people who are good at
feature engineering may not be good at
cloud management so what you want to do
is realize where people's individual
strengths are and use this as a road map
for personal development for example I
am terrible at visualization I am like I
can do it
it takes me four times longer than it
should to make it effective is
visualization I'm but I'm very good at
math so my strength is not in building a
dashboard or building a front-end to
view the data my strength is in
understanding the algorithm which means
that I should be looking towards people
who are good at that too to compliment
me in my team and then finally identify
weaknesses in your sack
where are your barriers where your
readiness level barriers I talked to
somebody yesterday who developed some
really cool algorithms and they wanted
to have a really cool front-end to do
the visualizations and they're like but
we don't know how to do this we're kind
of like doing this thing where we're
hacking things together and we just
don't have the time to build out that
technology so if that's what you're if
those are your barriers you need to be
able to identify them and that's where
you should focus your hiring or your
your professional development
and then finally what are you asking
your data scientists in your
organization actually to do
are you using their best strengths are
you using them you know do you have
actually have people that can get you
through those barriers and communicate
with the people that you need to in your
organization to start building data
products that's really all that I have
thank you very much I think there's a
couple of minutes left for questions and
yeah hopefully this is will help some of
you bring your products and actually set
them loose in the world in a positive
way that makes a difference thank you
[Applause]